you were talking earlier about kind of
telling the story and I think one thing
that people don't realize that you do
probably better than anyone I've ever
seen is you practice I've heard you
literally pitch liquid death probably
500 times while I'm with you as you're
handing the can and it was all before
that the big last fundraise right and so
like all of that repetition every time
wasn't exactly the same but it went from
hey there's is water in this can that
you know was kind of what I would assume
most people would start at 2 by the time
the 500th time I heard you say it I was
like damn that's pretty compelling like
there's not that many people were gonna
say no to that the funny thing is you
say practice but I it's like I don't in
my whole life I've never when I do talks
I don't write them down it's always off
the cuff I try people nuts but I don't
because I it's mostly because I have a
really bad memory like diagnosed with
ADHD 16% on memory it's just the pitch
I just miss based on people's reaction
right and I just adjust adjust it so
when I say 7,000 nose though 7,000 nose
got to a couple hundred yeses just
because every time I'm just watching
reaction am listening see reaction what
do they have questions about how can I
essentially in advance answer the
question in the [ __ ] so part of
pitching is repetition you can call it
practice but talking it out loud to
people normal people like gen pop who
aren't investors do they understand what
you're telling then through the lens and
investor every time you get the question
like I don't know why this why this why
this if you can weave in your narrative
that answer before you think you know
the questions are gonna come what you
want is a dialogue where you do pitch
for five minutes and the rest is just
like conversation not questions because
you've answered all these things like
why now why this you know why now why
would this work I don't understand if
you tell you pitch in a way by kind of
answering those questions along you
don't waste that 30 minutes you have
with an investor
I always think even though people say
it's an hour you really have my opinion
you have about 15 minutes like you know
maybe less you've got to capture them
inside the first few minutes 15 minutes
a meeting that goes longer than one hour
you have them the last thing I'll say is
there's a 24 hour rule I have if an
investor doesn't call you text you
message you help even like a tweet of
yours within 24 hours it's a it's a no
move on fast nose is all I've ever asked
for my investors look it's not I'm not
offended if you pass like it's if it's
not your things not your thing what's
the worst is slow nose because you're
just it's like hope to an entrepreneur
you're giving them hope and that sucks
like just cut it so they can move on
like they need to move on they need to
move on and so if you're an entrepreneur
there and you're pitching people if they
if they haven't done that to you know we
don't like don't waste energy hoping
right and you're not a teacher you are
not as an entrepreneur built to educate
everybody so just because an ambassador
ask the question does not mean you have
to answer it is not truth serum like it
is amazing when I found her like I told
him this like why would you tell them
everything like they're they're not on
the board they're not an investor that's
information only for us and so remember
the power dynamics is that I don't say I
never think say things like we're
raising money I don't like to say that
right and when I talk to investor I'm
talking about we're looking for people
who can be a part of this right would
you like the privilege to invest like
make it feel like it's a privilege like
they have to sell you a little bit it's
a really mental thing into the back pain
if anybody out there who's raised money
before the moment you get somebody you
get a term sheet all of a sudden you are
so much more confident too
next investor nothing actually changed
right except your confidence into that
next pitch and all sudden like the
momentum of the clothes happens if
you've ever raised money take that
feeling and try to pitch like that all
the time
pitch with confidence not arrogance is a
big difference don't pitch what they're
games I hate that pitch with confidence
that you're looking for somebody to be a
part of this that it is a it should be
rightfully so if you're building a
company that's going to be worth more
money they are lucky to be investing
right it's just it's this relationship
where you're saying look if you give us
dollars I'm in return giving making more
money but don't death the desperation
thing never works it's a really
interesting dynamic in a psychology
thing when raising money that your
shares and equity the company is very
very valuable treat it like so because
if you treat it like it's not why would
investor want to give you money if you
don't anything it's valuable so it's the
subtleties it's a lot of
subconsciousness around